what makes a good climax for me it's the
culmination of all the conflicts drama
and development all rolled into one in
action anime it typically comes in the
form of a final battle and with the
amount of shows we have in the medium
there are climaxes of plenty so for
today we'll be going over some of my
favorite final battles in anime also as
a final disclaimer spoilers are bound
because hey we're talking about action
anime final battles here that's more or
less given at this point so without
further ado let's get started this may
not be the first thing on a lot of
people's lists which is why i want to
start off with agame versus ez death
akame vs death is quite the ride i
remember when this first aired we were
just coming off the emotional storm of
tatsumi actually dying after defeating
the emperor and entrusting the finale to
akame with both sides suffering major
losses it was time for the final
showdown all chips are thrown in the
battle as both akame and ez death
unleash their trump cards on one another
akame with what people jokingly call her
ghoul for manages to land a poison blow
but that won't be enough to stop the
strongest enemy general in the end after
a dirty and gritty fight akame overcomes
as death's broken skill of stopping time
to land the decisive blow as death
chooses to die alongside tatsumi in a
last show of her love akame ga kill was
quite the contentious show back then
mostly due to the deaths and not
following the source material in a lot
of parts however with what the anime
team did in those anime original moments
i can't be too mad this final battle for
me is quite the nice finale and in some
ways i actually liked it more than the
manga events
well how's that for a star but before we
proceed i'd like to thank today's
sponsors disgaea rpg this guy rpg's a
turn-based mobile rpg based off the fan
favorite game franchise after years this
game finally had its much awaited global
release and it brings the goodness of
the tactical rpg classic straight to
mobile who could forget the series and
its complex combat and charming cast of
anti-heroes this guy at rpg brings back
the magic of the series and then some
adding some more characters to the mix
and revamping the combat system as you
fight your way to become the next
overlord of the netherworld my favorite
part of the game in addition to seeing
the return of the good old over-the-top
battles has to be the team-building
aspect to it with your units you can set
up various team comps and create the
perfect squad to wipe out all who dare
to defy you there's no better time to
start now because things are about to
heat up with the seven deadly sins clap
yeah you heard that right see your
favorite seven deadly sins characters in
action featuring old favorites like
meliodus gather and the rest of the sins
get these badass characters through the
event exclusive summons i'm going for
either barn or king personally speaking
oh and did i mention the loads and loads
of logging bonuses that we'll be getting
yeah perfect time to hop in and join the
fun lastly disgaea rpg communities are
among some of the best ones out there
the tightly knit communities just give
me so much fun through their activities
and i've gotten my fair share of gifts
from there too if you're up for a
tactical rpg that will test your tactics
to the fullest this gaia rpg is the game
for you download the game now and you
can use the code which i'll provide in
the description and get special gifts
for free enough of that though and we
move on to a series that shaped a bit of
my high school days samurai champloo
samurai champloo is being quite
forgotten these days which is a real
shame being a simple two-course show
with a neatly tight ending does that
unless you were able to break out to the
mainstream big time like some of its
contemporaries did you find yourself
lost in the annals of time the first
thing people remember samurai shamplo
for is its stylishness the whole thing
is just oozing with style and an
aesthetic that's so unique for its time
and i'd argue that that even holds true
now but more than just style and
aesthetics it's also a great story with
a fun character dynamic and of course
awesome fights like the final battle the
actual fight is good and filled with
action but i'd like to bring your
attention to just how well this fight is
placed in terms of the character's
development timelines what a poetic
ending filled with parallelisms between
jin and mugen's fighting stars and how
they had to adapt there's the symbolism
with jin being unpredictable as well as
fighting for someone mugen finally
having to be precise to not brute force
his way through an opponent for once and
an amazing final technique to cap things
off among samurai anime i'd say that
samurai shampoo is one of the best ones
it has a unique feel to it and it's
filled to the brim with fights like this
that ooze charisma
[Music]
when it comes to inspirationally
thematic battles however my vote goes to
gurren lagann's final battle
i can't speak enough on how much i love
this final battle ttgl has had a lot of
great moments in its run but the finale
is no doubt my favorite seeing everyone
from allies to former enemies working
together while the legendary opening
plays in the background
man i'm getting goosebumps just
re-watching this moment as i'm writing
everything down here it's as over the
top as you'd expect from the trigger
pedigree but what really gets me here
isn't the animation it's not the
flashing lights and the shouting it's
the message behind it i dare say that
even someone who's never watched the
series can watch this battle and still
feel empowered by it i personally am
more of a sucker for the inspirational
positive finales in anime and this one
encapsulates that so well it makes me
feel good to have characters shout about
the true strength and potential of
humanity and while we see it pretty
often now even in the more unexpected
places like the fake grand order series
for one guru nagan is one of the shows
that did it best the whole show has been
a wild ride about overcoming trials
successfully fighting against fate and
the possibilities that lie ahead for the
human race and it's genuinely empowering
and heartwarming to see it capped off
with this battle
and now for a cinematic inclusion we
have nanashi versus luo lang
[Music]
i feature this fight quite a lot and i
still stand my ground on how it's one of
the best one-on-one battles that you can
ask for in capping off a movie filled
with action and drama sword of the
stranger also had the benefit of one of
the strongest opening sequences in anime
cinema building insane amounts of hype
for luo lang and making the final
showdown against him well worth the wait
well the fight itself it doesn't
disappoint in the slightest well i've
got a lot of love for the supernatural
and the fantastic i think that a clean
sword fight that is without all those
magical powers is also good i mean i had
samurai shampoo not too long ago this
nanashi versus lulang fight can be
compared to that in a sense the only
kicker is that this one has the backing
of a film's budget on his side so it
looks even more beautiful it's not quite
you for table tea or anything like that
but in its time and even now arguably
sword of the stranger has some of the
best battle sequences in anime cinema
the emotional stakes of the fight along
with the actual fight choreography make
this one of my favorite final battles
we return to the world of magic and
science with full metal alchemist
brotherhood's final battle
the final showdown against father will
always hold a place in my heart due to
how well it captures the essence and
message of full metal alchemist
thematically fullmetal alchemist has
been one of the strongest anime out
there and it stays strong to its message
all throughout the criticisms i saw
about this battle was that it's not as
grand as people would have liked but i
beg to disagree for me fma isn't all
about a huge climactic battle the
characters are all flawed and weak
because of their humanity and the battle
with ed punching out father while
everyone cheers on is a testament to the
message that despite being weak we all
find strength when we stay united that's
in contrast to father who's lost all in
his search for even more power this was
the moment when the united wheels of
humanity took down a god but that's not
all the lead-up to the battle also had a
lot of memorable moments like greed
coming to terms with his will all coming
together to make a very satisfying
finale fma is the one anime where a huge
climactic battle like the one from say
guru lagan would look completely out of
place
ironically that can't be said about
something like fate zero
while fate zero being a fake series has
its share of servants with their grand
finishing moves as well as some big time
confrontations such as ryder vs
gilgamesh the final battle is also
fittingly a showdown between mere mortal
men kiray vs kiritsugu is another of my
favorite final battles and that's not
just my fate buyers talking here the
other fake final fights have been visual
spectacles but how often do you see the
masters get down and dirty to do the
fighting holding nothing back sure
gilgamesh vs shiro was cathartic and the
theater battle from babylonia is one of
my favorite raid boss finales of all
time but those they're the things you
expect from fate what you don't expect
is for the fate of the world to lie in
the hands of two humans duking it out in
a spectacle not just some quick punches
and attacks like the rin versus sakura
and shiro vs kirei moments in spring
song you can really feel the intensity
watching kiritsugu vs kirei and when you
put the two people with nothing to lose
and everything to gain in a
no-holds-barred showdown
good things are always gonna happen
i feel jojo deserves a spot on this list
especially with how much i enjoyed
giordaro versus dio
[Music]
with how much of an important footnote
in anime culture jojo's become it
becomes harder and harder to find that
one final fight to top it off they're
all awesome in their own way so what can
i do still i personally feel that the
best and most iconic one is jodaro vs
dio and no it's not because the fight is
one that spawned a lot of memes that the
community still loves to this very day
for me dio's just the quintessential
jojo villain the most important one and
the one with the most charisma or appeal
and i'm sure a lot of you jojo fans will
agree with me dio is the most
charismatic villain of them all and he's
an immortal vampire to boot how someone
like jodaro gonna stand up to him it's
the fight that has all the build up that
you'd want from a final battle while
doubling as an underdog fight the
fight's been over 40 episodes in the
making and every second of the face-off
made it worth the wait
as if i can do a top fight video without
talking about naruto's final battle in
some form here's naruto versus sasuke
for me what makes this fight so awesome
is the sheer build-up there are many
ways for an anime final battle to be
awesome a lot of that has to do with the
actual fight as well as the context and
the emotional investment i think that
naruto vs sasuke takes off both of those
boxes splendidly in its finale the first
ones are given since both combatants at
peak power have eye-catching abilities
that work so well in contrast to each
other but how about the second one i
said this before and i'm gonna say it
again this is just the perfect final
battle for naruto because sasuke serves
the final challenge for our hero to go
through before capping off the journey
yes you could argue that someone like
madara or karguya would be more of a
physical challenge but what better final
opponent than your equal who's your
philosophical antithesis you don't get
those sort of emotional stakes with the
two that i just mentioned but for
someone you've been rivals with forever
you've spent entire arc searching for
and trying to find the good him it's
just perfect it's not every day that you
see a shonen anime have a rival
character as the final boss without
brainwashing shenanigans or the like i
think that it's an awesome way to go
about things naruto and sasuke put it
all on the line for their long-awaited
showdown finishing off with essentially
a draw driving home the message that
it's not all about the physical victory
but the emotional one
[Music]
i think that this video has gone on for
quite long now so if i were to pick a
fight to finish off my list of favorite
final battles then i would go for
gintoki vs utsuro
gintama the final capped off a long
world wind of a ride putting a fitting
end to one of the best shown end
franchises there is for me the fight
itself while not exactly a show of the
animated team flexing their skills hits
especially hard on an emotional level
it's a whole culmination of a long
journey and atsuro serves as the perfect
final antagonist while people may take
note of how overpowered he is i think
that the more important takeaway is that
in a similar vein to the naruto versus
sasuke fight a while ago this is a final
confrontation of world views and wills
utsuru doesn't only challenge our heroes
particularly gintoki in a battle of
swords but also everything in toki stood
for now that my friends deserves an
entire write-up on its own so i'll just
leave it at that q the sad farewell to
takasugi 2 once it's all said and done
you'll be dearly missed overall this
fight had a lot of impact on me i won't
outright put it up as one of those
fights that will change how you see
anime forever or anything outrageous
like that but it's a damn good fight
that will live on in history as a solid
finale to gintama
and with that i wrap up the list of my
favorite final battles in anime how
about you what are your favorites what
would you want to recommend to me i'm
all is so head down to the comments
section and let me know if you liked the
video show it by hitting the like button
and subscribing you can also show your
appreciation through channel memberships
and my patreon oh and vinnie tube is on
instagram now and that's where i'll be
sharing links to some of my videos as
well as some news regarding the industry
if you're someone who'd like to help the
instagram grow make sure to drop by and
follow the page don't forget to check
out our sponsors game disgaea rpg
there's a link in the description box so
that's it for today hope you had a great
time and i'll see you in the next one
[Music]
you